In the last few years, we've
seen a staggering increase
in media consumption on the
web, while worldwide internet
bandwidth has not
kept the same pace.
To help with this,
my name is Vignesh,
I'm here to talk about
how you can take advantage
of a new video
format for the web.
Video already accounts
for more than half
of the peak internet bandwidth
worldwide and almost 2/3
in certain parts of the world.
The WebM project is a collection
of open tools and media
technologies that aim to
tackle the challenges of media
at internet scale and enable
open and free communication
of ideas through media.
The WebM project develops two
video codecs-- VP8 and VP9--
the media container,
that's the WebM container,
and an image format called WebP.
These technologies
together power
some of your favorite Google
services at a large scale,
like YouTube and Hangouts.
They're also widely
used on the web.
For example, Netflix
and Facebook use WebP.
We announced VP9, our next
generation open video codec,
at I/O 2013.
Videos encoded in VP9
see up to 50% improvement
in conversion efficiency.
Today, VP9 video playback is
supported in Chrome, Firefox,
Opera, and Android.
Since I/O 2013, we've
improved both the speed
and the compression
efficiency of VP9.
This has enabled
YouTube to choose
VP9 as their next
generation video codec.
If you're curious about
updates to VP9 since I/O 2013,
check out our video,
"Updates to VP9."
Additionally, if you
want to deep dive
into the encoding techniques
used to achieve the compression
performance, we highly
recommend checking out
our I/O 2013 session on VP9.
It's called, "The New
Open Video Codec."
In this video,
I'm going to focus
on how to easily encode VP9
videos using open source tools
and then go on to talk about how
we can play those videos back.
First, the simple
progressive encode.
Let's say that you just
want to encode a video
and want it to be played
back across multiple devices.
In other words,
all you want to do
is just host a video and play
it back using the video tag
by using the hosted
URL as the source.
Here is how you do it.
Progressive encodes are simple
and will allow any supported
VP9 player to download
and play the file.
Examples include Chrome,
Firefox, and Android.
Here is how you create a
progressive VP9 encode.
All you need to do is
bind ffmpeg to your input
file and ask it to
use the VP9 encoder.
Here's how you play
back this video.
That was simple, wasn't it?
If you have ideas on
making it even simpler
we welcome all your
thoughts at this email.
OK, now if you plan to
serve video over the web,
chances are that you
want to take advantage
of some of the
HTML5 technologies
that'll allow you to
provide a great streaming
experience to your customers.
This has traditionally
been tough,
and an industry
standard was spawned
to solve this called DASH.
DASH stands for Dynamic
Adaptive Streaming over HTTP,
and it allows you to
select the stream that'll
provide the best perceived
quality, depending
on the client's constraints.
Traditionally,
this is [INAUDIBLE]
with the term adaptive playback.
At Google, we use adaptive
playback using DASH and HTML5
technologies like
media source extensions
to provide a great streaming
experience on YouTube.
For example, with
VP9 and DASH, we've
improved the key metrics of
streaming videos-- rebuffers.
VP9 DASH videos have
improved rebuffers
by 25% in developed markets and
up to 50% in emerging markets.
We've heard from
multimedia developers
that creating a DASH manifest
for VP9 has been challenging.
I'm happy to announce that
we've worked with ffmpeg
and are announcing a
set of open source tools
to simplify the
encoding process.
Let's now take a look at how
to encode VP9 DASH videos
and generate the manifest.
Encoding a VP9 video to
be compatible with DASH
is very similar to doing
a progressive encode,
with a few minor changes.
For DASH, the
video and audio has
to be encoded separately
into two different files.
You also need to pass
the extra DASH parameter
to ffmpeg so that it
creates WebM files which
are DASH compliant.
Now that you have the video
and audio files encoded,
you can make use of the
WebM DASH manifest tool
to generate the
DASH manifest file.
The WebM DASH manifest tool is
part of the WebM Tools project.
You can download
the tools we use
to create DASH streams and the
manifest from the links found
on this slide.
OK, let's now talk about
integrating a video player
to play back VP9
videos using DASH.
Just to reiterate,
VP9 decoding support
is already available in Chrome,
Firefox, Opera, and Android.
Together, they represent over
a billion devices and browsers
that can playback VP9 video.
But creating a VP9 player
to play back adaptive video
is a little more
difficult, although there
are two players
that makes it easy.
To put together they enable
adaptive VP9 playback on two
of the most popular platforms--
the web and Android.
First off, Android.
YouTube open sources
a player called
Exoplayer that supports
adaptive playback of VP9.
To know more about how to use
Exoplayer to enable VP9 DASH
videos in your app, see the
talk by YouTube on Exoplayer.
For the web, we added
VP9 DASH support
to dash.js, which is a
fantastic all-in-one media
player built entirely in HTML5.
For more information on how
we use dash.js to play back
adaptive VP9 videos, you can
follow the link on this slide.
With these tools, encoding
and decoding VP9 content
has never been easier.
Now it's your job to
tell a great story
or ship the next
great video player.
And of course,
we're here to help.
Drop us a line at
webm-discuss@webmproject.org.
Thank you.